हुआ था नमस्कार आप सभी का स्वागत है जर्मन
सीखिए हिंदी में कि नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आज
हम सीखने वाले हैं जर्मन ग्रीटिंग तुझे
चाहिए शुरू करते हैं तो जर्मन प्रिंटिंग
शुरू करने से पहले हम कोई चीज समझ में
लेती है वह है कि फॉर्मल और इनफॉरमल
कन्वर्सेशन तो वाटर फॉर्मल एंड इनफॉरमल
कन्वर्सेशन तो इनफॉरमल कन्वरसेशंस मतलब
क्या है जब अपने दोस्त के साथ बात कर रहे
हैं जब आप अपने दोस्त के साथ बात कर रहे
हो तो आप ज्यादा कुछ सोचते नहीं आप उसको
तू करके मिलाते हो कि तू क्या कर रहा है
कहां से आ रहा है एंड यूअर आप नार्मल काजू
लैंग्वेज का यूज कर रहे हैं वहीं जब आप
अपने बॉस के साथ चकली के साथ बात कर रहे
हो तो आप वर्ल्ड का यूज करते हो आपका बाय
आपने क्या किया अनिवार्य वोटिंग सारी जो
लैंग्वेज है वह ऑफिशियल यूज करते हो तो यह
है फॉर्मल वर्सेस इनफॉरमल हिंदी में तो
कि यह आप वैसे ही जर्मन में भी जब
इनफॉर्मली बात करोगे तो आप दूध का यूज
करोगे दूर मतलब तू और जब आप और मलिक बात
करोगे तब आ आप यानि जी का यूज करोगे अब हम
दोनों भी फॉर्मेट में फॉर्मल और इन फॉर्मल
फॉर्मेट में ग्रीटिंग कैसे बनाने हैं वह
देखिए तो सबसे पहले जब आप किसी से पहली
बार मिलते हैं मिनिमम मीटिंग चम्मच जब
दोस्तों मिलते हैं और तो जब मन में भी
इंग्लिश की तरह ही हर लव हम लोग करोगे
बड़ी अगर आप किसी ऑफिशियल बनने से यह
फॉर्म मिल रहे हो तो डिपेंडिंग अपऑन द
टाइम ऑफ द डे आप बोलोगे घूंट मारके पिछे
कि गुड्डन मार्कल मतलब गुड मॉर्निंग या
फिर गुड अंटा घाट आप मतलब गुड डे या फिर *
आप मतलब गुड इवनिंग ओके वहीं अगर आप किसी
को किसी को बाय बोल है अपने दोस्त को
इंफॉर्म ही बाइबिल है तो रुके चिल्ड्रंस
चील
हैं और अगर आपको फैमिली बाय बोल रहा है
किसी को तो आप बोलोगे आफ लीडर्स हैं
कि ट्विटर से है मतलब लूजली ट्रांसलेट्स
होता है फिर मिलेंगे फिर मिलेंगे लेकिन जब
आप जर्मनी में रहोगे और डिपेंडिंग अपऑन ऑल
द ईयर थोड़े अलग उसके वेरियंट्स है जैसे
कि जहां मैं रहता हूं बायर्न में बायर्न
में आप किसी को हेलो करते हैं वह ग्रीस कर
ग्रीस कॉर्ड बोलते हैं या फिर बिकॉज ई
अप्रोच टो इटली इटली का बहुत ज्यादा
प्रभाव है तो बाइक करते वक्त क्या चाव
करते हैं पर जब तक हम नए हैं हम जो रेगुलर
एक्सप्रेशन से वही यूज करेंगे तो हम हाय
को बोलेंगे हमलों और बाइक को मिलेंगे इन
चिल्ड्रन
अच्छा ठीक है अभी किसी वक्त किसी को आप
में सपोच आप अपने दोस्त को मिले तो पहला
प्रश्न क्या करते हैं और हिंदी में क्या
भाई क्या चल रहा है तो जैसे मैंने बोला
हिंदी और जर्मन में बहुत सारी सिमिलरिटीज
है इसमें सेक्सी मराठी है यह आप लिटरल
जर्मन में भी यही पूछते हो क्या भाई क्या
चल रहा है वी गेट एस डियर बीइंग ए टेस्ट
ईयर या फिर शॉर्ट में बिगेस्ट बिगेस्ट
क्या चल रहा है तो किसी ने आपको पूछा कि
क्या चल रहा है तो आप क्या बोलोगे इसलिए
म्यूट अच्छे से मिल रहा है या फिर गुड
अच्छा है और इससे मैं आपको पूछा है कि वह
कैसा चल रहा है तो आपको भी उसको पूछना
पड़ेगा और तेरा कुंडिय कुंडिय वही बोला न
इधर भी अच्छी तरह अवगुन अघ ओघ तो यह जो इन
फॉर प्रमोशन कैसे होगा देखते हैं
कि मुझे किसी कोच इंडिकेटर या फिर पीके
स्किन या गुड़ और नियर अबाउट यह
इंफोर्मेशन वहीं अगर आप फैमिली मिले तो
कैसे कैसे चल रहा है गैदर्ड इन थे वी गेट
80 न तो वह अच्छा चल रहा है ना
यहां पर आपका OTP न उनकी न ऑफ बिर्थ मेरा
अच्छा फिर से इसका मेरे कैसे होगा में
बताते हैं
को भी के इसकी न इसके लिए कोर्ट उनकी न और
गुड अभी किसी ने पूछा तुम्हारा कैसे चल
रहा है तो इसका आंसर आप लिस्ट घूंट या फिर
जोड़ लूंगा ओके ओके भी देख सकते हो बट
जनरली हम वह नहीं करेंगे किसने पूछा कैसा
चल रहा है अच्छा चाहिए
कि यह सब को तो अब हम को हाय बाय कैसा चल
रहा है पूछना है नेक्स्ट इंपोर्टेंट वक्त
सर सॉरी लिए थैंक यू ओके तो अगर आपको
जर्मन में सॉरी यार एक्सक्यूज मी बोलना है
तो एक बहुत बड़ा वर्ग है वह वर्ग या देखते
हैं एनुअल डे घुम अनइंस्टॉल डिकोम अज्ञात
युवक बड़ा लगता है पर आप इतनी बार यूज
करोगे कि वह अपने आप ही इजी हो जाए पर फिर
भी अगर आपको थोड़ा हार्ड लगता है तो आप
यूज कर सकते हो इस टूट मियां लाइन है
स्ट्रैट लाइन है यह सोनिया स्कूल में कि
कि अगर आप किसी ने मदद की है और आप को
थैंक यू बोल रहा है तो अब जर्मन में बोलो
कि डार्क
कि डाकपाल मतलब थैंक्यू आगे इसके पेमेंट
हो सकते हैं थैंक यू सो मच थैंक्स अलॉट व
होंगे इस फील्ड एंड एकेडमिक जहर एक्सीलेटर
अभियुक्त दम कुड़ी अगर किसी ने आपको
थैंक्यू बोला तो आपको यह और वेलकम होगा
जर्मन में बिट या फिर ब्रिटिश है
हो चुके या फिर आप ऐसे भी बोल सकते हो कि
हम उन्हें ढूंढ तुम्हारी मदद करके मेरी
खुशी हुई तो आप बनाओगे गैरसैंण गहरा मतलब
है पीली तो किसी ने आपको बोला डांस कर तो
आप बोलोगे जब ट्विटर या फिर गहरा ओके तो
अभी हमने सारे जो इंपॉर्टेंट जर्मन
कीवर्ड्स एग्री
कि हम उस तक हम रिवीजन ले
को सबसे पहले अगर किसी को हाय करना है
इनफॉर्मली हल फॉर हुई ए गुड मॉर्निंग गुड
सांय - पेड़
हुआ था अरे किसी को बाय करना है इन फॉर्मल
इक चीज़ फॉर मलिक और ट्विटर से अगर किसी
को पहली बार मैंने कैसे चल रहा है पूछना
है तो इन्फॉर्मेशन हो गया कि ग्लिसरीन
ठाकुर पवन दिया अब तक यही कन्वर्सेशन
फॉर्मली होकर विकेट इसकी नन
है इसलिए गुट उनकी नल और घूंट अगर किसी ने
आपको अगर आपको किसी को सॉरी बोल है तो
बोलोगे Instagram या फिर स्ट्रीट मिलाएं
अगर किसी को थैंक्यू बोलना है तो आप
बोलोगे डाउन खेल धार्मिक और अगर किसी ने
आपको थैंक्यू बोला तो आप बोलोगे बीट योर
वेलकम या फिर गैर हैप्पी मुझे आशा है कि
आप सबको जर्मन रेटिंग ठीक से समझ में आए
हैं अगर आपको कोई भी डाउट है तो आप कमेंट
में लिख सकते हो और उसका आंसर देने की
पूरी कोशिश करूंगा मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
एपिसोड में धन्यवाद